[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à espace
autochtones en direct je m'appelle
anne-marie yvon je vous invite à écouter
cette conversation qui va être vraiment
intéressant parce qu'elle nous entraîne
dans un débat très inhabituel on va
parler d'appropriation culturel mais pas
entre des autochtones et des non
autochtones mais plutôt entre des autres
entre des autochtones eux mêmes en fait
entre eux cette fois ci des inuit et des
premières nations
c'est la première fois que ça se produit
et on va expliquer dans quel contexte
mais d'abord je vous présente les
personnes autour de la table m isabelle
picard de nouveau avec nous cette
semaine merci bien sûr vous êtes
chroniqueuse un espace autochtone alors
votre avis va être vraiment intéressant
et ce dont vous allez nous parler
aujourd'hui donc l'appropriation
culturelle bonjour bonjour
et puis mine à ces galops waits nina
vous êtes une artiste en fait j'allais
dire inuit mais pas seulement il nous ya
il ya tout un mélange de communautés
dans vos origines n'est ce pas oui alors
qu'elles sont elles ces origines ma
merviel de l'inric alors je suis et mon
père vienne de lord alberta alors je
suis aussi donné d'accord
et puis vous parlait très bien français
parce que vous avez été élevé au québec
oui je suis un des survivants dès les
années 60
exactement on va raconter l'histoire
en fait non avant de commencer par cette
histoire on va parler d'une nouvelle qui
est sorti donc aujourd'hui vendredi 12
avril une nouvelle qui est quand même
très importante parce qu'elle a fait les
manchettes au cours des derniers mois
c'est l'université mais guy qui a
finalement annoncé qu'elle allait
changer le nom des équipes sportives de
l'université mcgill
on sait que les équipes s'appelait les
redmen les hommes rouges ça a été
contestée il ya un jeune homme
d'ailleurs lui il est
le commissaire aux affaires autochtones
de l'association étudiante il s'appelle
de thomas ce giro zec et c'est lui qui
avait mené cette campagne pour faire
enlever ce nom les abeilles commentaire
le nom finalement va disparaître on n'a
pas encore choisi quel nom va le
remplacer mais c'est une bonne nouvelle
ben et enfin oui c'est une bonne
nouvelle je pense que plusieurs cégeps
et universités qui sont un peu dans
cette réflexion la raison lancé l'école
agence écossais ils y ont des équipes
qui s'appelle les indiens on a eu une
belle discussion dans les dernières
semaines à savoir comment on pouvait
peut-être changer le nom des tarnais
façon pas toute cette partie de
l'histoire de du collage et dans ce cas
c'est mon université parce que c'est
depuis 1920 que les équipes portent
quand même selon le donc cette partie de
l'histoire là il faut pas à travers tout
ça non plus toutes les facéties dont là
parce que ça fait partie de l'art du
temps maintenant on est en 2019
c'est bien que les choses évoluent et
orange nina qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous l'avez suivi ce débat avec
l'université mcgill même aussi j'ai lu
les nouvelles ce matin et j'écoutais les
nouvelles et puis pour moi c'est une
bonne chose parce que c'est leur
évolution
c'est plutôt 11e il ya plus d excuse
maintenant pour pas être hour ou comme
si conscient d'avec de tous deux le
sujet de deux races et souhaiterait
justice avec les noms alors oui moi
c'est un mouvement pour par l'avancement
oui le live de la culture autochtone ou
comment le mieux respecté
oui on vertus on est compréhensible on
comprend mieux en fait la réalité des
autochtones et là c'est peut-être bon un
premier exemple d'une bonne façon de
faire
oui alors maintenant l'histoire qui nous
concerne elle a commencé il ya pas très
longtemps autour du 1er avril ou à peu
près lorsqu'on a révélé le nom des
artistes qui avaient été mis en
nomination dans diverses catégories d'un
événement qui s'affalait des gentlemen
et puis à ce moment là on a présenté une
artiste elle écrit d'origine n'est ce
pas là je sais pas comment prononcer son
nom d'artiste si ques 6 kw sc coni le
ground ça c'est son nom est mais son nom
d'artiste seaquest donc elle a été
nommée dans la catégorie meilleure abu
album folk et avec une chanson qui en
fait est de intègre des champs de style
inuit des chants de gorge
alors évidemment ça fait réagir beaucoup
d'artistes inuit qui ont dit ben nous
aussi l est est présenté dans cette
catégorie là nous on se retire
complètement donc avant d'aller plus
loin il a belle qu'est ce que sont ces
unes des génisses musicaux - en fait les
génisses music awards c'est un peu
l'équivalent des juno ou encore de
l'adisq au québec mais exclusivement
pour la musique autochtone c'est un gala
qui lui que lieu une fois par année et
qui récompense les meilleurs artistes
que ce soit au niveau meilleur album rap
meilleur album folk rock mais aussi des
catégories super intéressante et propres
aux premières nations comme meilleur
disent ne pas avoir traditionnels ou
contemporains ou donc tout ça aussi que
s'inscrit à l'intérieur du gala
maintenant le gala lui même s'est
inscrit dans quelque chose de beaucoup
plus gros qu'on appelle le festival
manitou habits qui qui prend place
quatre ou cinq jours par année à
winnipeg
chaque fois chaque année et donc on va
en même temps oui ça cependant les ondes
et janis musicaux etc le lundi 9
musicaux est en fait c'est un événement
qui en fait partie mais il ya d'autres
événements très importants dont très
groupe awa qui inclut 800 danseurs quand
même c'est pas rien on sait que winnipeg
c'est la ville canadienne où il ya plus
de docteurs en milieu urbain donc
c'était pas une coïncidence qu'on fasse
tout cela il ya des conférences sont les
la musique autochtone marché des foires
commerciales aussi au niveau d'octobre
des compétitions de gigue très populaire
chez nos amis du territoire du nord chez
les médecins aussi oui absolument
il ya des défis artistiques et je dire
en quoi le tout tous cet événement locks
appel je le rappelle le festival manitou
habits se veut un rassemblement qui va
célébrer la culture le patrimoine
autochtone pour unifier mais aussi
beaucoup pour pour faire connaître et
pour la petite histoire le nom du
festival manitou abissa a été donné lors
d'une cérémonie temps quand on parle du
sacré l'importance sacré même le nom et
provient d'une cérémonie et donc sa
porte le nom d'un site sacré qui est
l'un des plus importants lieux sacrés au
canada même qui est reconnu par les
autochtones qui est située à cet endroit
lui va en fait situé dans la région
ouest de whiteshell au manitoba donc
c'est dans la même province c'est pas
tellement loin et le mot manitou habits
signifie où le créateur est assis donc
c'est donc de montrer l'importance de ce
côté sacré l'oeil voilà donc pour
revenir aux indigènes is music awards
cette année j'ai quand même regardé au
niveau du québec c'est sûr que ça
m'intéressait davantage savoir quels
sont les artistes autochtones qui ont
été nommés je n'en ai trouvé que
peut-être que je me trompe
j'ai regardé ça peut-être en août je
connais pas mais c'est mike paul en innu
de bastia qui en omettant des
nominations pour son disque origine dans
la catégorie album langue inuit
autochtone ou francophones donc il y à
une catégorie qui inclut tout ça et lui
il est à l'intérieur de ça il faut il
faut savoir j'ai pas vu il s'appuie
j'étais quand même surprise ils veulent
quand même été en nomination pour un
juge unique et quand même ivoiriens donc
elle n'y est pas évidemment jérémy
d'autres y est
deux nominations on sera là d'ailleurs
parce qu'il était en europe en tournée
actuellement ces affaires le bol et j'ai
pas eu de monde nous sommes avec oui
j'ai vraiment bien parce que ces
discours sont tellement intéressant on
est riche de leçons et est donc au
québec on un équivalent parce que bon
depuis depuis quatre ans qui s'appelle
le gala thé wiggles qui va avoir lieu
donc 4e édition en août prochain alors
un peu voilà un peu ce que c'est que les
fans de johnny smith & co mina ce que
vous en avez déjà fait partie est ce que
vous avez déjà été nommés alors de cet
événement là nous j'ai comme artiste bas
que je fais le chant de gorge inuit et
je vais partie d'un groupe qui s'appelle
oktoecho oui puis aussi je fais je fais
des champs avec mokren industrie nominal
et puis je n'ai pas encore fait un cd
moi même je
j'aime bien assisté avec j'aime bien
jouer avec d'autres à ses disciples et
en musique vous êtes vous jouer du
tambour aussi puis vous êtes violence et
oui c'est ça quand j'étais juge plus
aujourd'hui moi mais lorsque dans le
dans votre groupe oktoecho il n'y a pas
que des autochtones
non c'est ce mélange on se mélange
on utilise l'aude oui il vient le hoodia
un violoncelliste il ya pianiste il ya
chanteuses et chanteurs belle et
instructif mais là sachant le
différentes façons différents styles et
il ya mon ami l'édito qui et chanteuses
de gorge il est aussi et il ya pour les
tambours c'est l'artiste curable mais
c'est tout ce mélange de styles de vélo
east
finalement vous falloir prier sur
culturelle dans diverses
oui si l'on fait un mélange on fait leur
éloge mais une des choses qui est très
important avec octobre par exemple c'est
que on explique à l'ats au début
l'important c'est que le chant de gorge
qu'on fait c'est ça fait un t1 partie
intégrale de la musique mais aussi c'est
fait on n'a qu'à en accord avec la
direction des aînés ça veut dire qu'on a
demandé d autres chanteuses de gorge
limite si on avait le droit de fait ils
mélangent pourrait bien respecté les
règles qui nous ont été dits quand nous
on a appris comment faire le change
d'accord mais comme par exemple
l'emprunt du sud parce que dans votre
groupe il ya une artiste qui est
originaire des pays où le ou des toits
elysées oui c'est exactement ça c'est
katia maddens kiwis qui joue bien
le husa les incroyants fait les changes
c'est une façon de respecter les deux
cultures sans être un geek l'un de
l'autre alors jamais je pourrais dire
ben je viens d'un pays que je peux
apprendre l'aude mais j'aurais lu elle
non plus annuels dirai jamais que l je
sais comment faire un chant de gorge
alors je vais juste les jantes et moi
même oui oui
alors qu'est ce qui dérange en fait dans
le cas qui nous concerne les greens des
djinns music awards
pourquoi est-ce que ça dérange qu'une
artiste qui est autochtone bon allez des
premières nations elle n'est pas inuit
qu'elle ait eu envie d'intégrer le chant
de gorge dans sa pratique
c'est une bonne question c'est une des
premières fois qu'on indices qui sont
comme ça parce que jamais comme vous et
dyala au début c'est plutôt les nôtres à
utiliser vous approprier la musique
swing actes dans ce cas là c'est
vraiment le le le fait qu' elle n'a pas
éclairé chanteuses de gorge
il nous est pour faire ce parti là aussi
c'est le fait que c'est le chant de
gorge nouée t'ai pas vue comme un
certain deschamps cérémonial alors c'est
peut-être vus comme plus il n'ira plus
fait pour ajouter un son différent s'est
pas vraiment vu comme un nanar elle même
ou un individuel et puis le champion
s'est pas vue comme cérémonie alors dans
les premières nations je sais les champs
chanter donc durant les cérémonies sont
vraiment vu comme sacrée alors elle peut
pas les changer alors si moi je chante
s'il ya quelqu'un any kind qu'il donne
un chante un champ son de tambours ils
vont elles vont me dire ben ils vont me
dire si je le droit d'être enregistrés
c'est qu'ils vont dire que vous pouvez
faire en public
mais le changement chez vue plutôt comme
un art qui est fait en public mais il
n'y a pas de protocole comme tel pour
les protéger par contre en 2001 par
exemple il y avait des rassemblements
appauvri noc des chanteuses de gorge
l'âge de 3 ans à 80 3 ans et un grand
rassemblement
puis alors là commençait vraiment à
parler des droits de comment protéger le
chanteur alors la question de l c'est
quoi le conflit c'est le fait que le
chant de gorge comme art est pas
respectée comme un art individuel dans
le sens que l artiste a vu que c'était
il y aura pas problème de l'approprier
de 15h oui oui mais elle n'a pas essayé
de travailler avec une artiste inuvik là
dessus
lorsqu'elle a préparé cette pièce là en
particulier oui c'est vrai qu'elle a
tout essayé mais il ya tant de chantage
de gorge ou tard il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup à ottawa morial on a nos navic
que sa une ça lui prendrait un peu de
temps pour en trouver un donneur le
parti de jean nos collègues de siby cndd
ne sont fins palais un peu comme ça il
ya et il y avait aussi une artiste
minutes qui est invité et qui disait que
le fait que
madame la grande n'avait pas eu la
bénédiction en fait de la communauté
inuite
ça a joué beaucoup dans dans la réaction
finalement des bruits des chanteuses de
gorge
est ce que vous êtes d'accord oui parce
que c'est elle a assumé qu'il s'agirait
correct qu'elle va juste ajouter des
sons de chants de gorge comme le change
aux c'est pas il ya eu ni répertoire
moi quand j'ai appris comment faire le
championnat mais avec courage et il est
aidé mart
il y avait des raisons qui ont été a
pris aussi c'était pas juste comment la
faire mais c'était comment le protéger
vous avez le droit de le transmettre à
vos filles vous avez le droit de
partager avec d'autres familles limites
mais vous donnez pas de classe de chant
de gorge est beaucoup de monde qui me
demandent à ce que je souhaite qu'on dit
est ce qu'il ya des cours de chant de
gorge mais c'est vraiment bien dit que
bien expliqués à nous convaincre ans et
de pins montré étonnement parce que
c'est quelque chose qui est sacré ben
c'est protéger dans la communauté
alors c'est le fait qu'elle a assumée
delajoux a ajouté à son il nous est un
sens que ça c'était vraiment
l'impression que ça donne à nous dans la
communauté c'est que on n'est pas
nationale respecte et on n'est pas le
commun à respecter on n'a pas le
demander de quoi on peut l'approprier
qu'est-ce qu'on veut les cas milk
les habits traditionnels ben c'est pas
grave on digital tonnes pc c'est pas
comme ça si vous demandez par exemple
infâme oracle pour un cadre de la
communauté sinon ils peuvent chanter les
chansons de roland garros pour les
cérémonies jamais jamais jamais il
ajouté comme son moral
c'est parce que c'est vu comme ça crie
mais comme le tueur nous mettons n'a pas
de protocole sacré ce sacré le mot sacré
pas dans notre vocabulaire vraiment
c'est voici comment nous respecter oui
comment sont nés les chants de gorge
parce que j'ai lu plus
version les gens de gorge son nez un peu
comme elle je voyais que cette année ou
alors ça peut être aussi une berceuse
auprès des enfants
oui c'est un passe temps pour nous c'est
un passe-temps c'est l'appât stocks ont
fait pendant des milliers d'années et ça
vient des cendres de la nature du grand
nord alors que ça peut être ça soit le
vent la rivière les oiseaux différents
animaux qui c'est un façon de sait
comment à canon alors une femme a
commencé avec l'ensemble comme pilote
femme rentre pas dans l'ouest et l'est 5
puis la femme qui rigolent en premier
ici est hyper affectueux
exactement c'est très ludique du golfe
mais c'est une façon par exemple aussi
le chant de ganges
chaque femme chaque maire à leurs
propres chansons pour leurs enfants
c'est une façon de bach c'est parce
qu'on parlait bébé astronautes d'eau
dans la mare outils et c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui fait partie de la
communauté de la culture nos temps et
quand on parle l'appropriation
culturelle
habituellement on dit bon que c'est une
appropriation par une culture dominante
oui on se retrouve là dedans dans ce cas
la première nation et nous en fait c'est
qu'il ya comme deux conditions bien
celle là et le peut-être qu'on se
retrouve moins dans ce cas ci mais
encore là on peut en discuter parce que
les inuits sont sentis nations les
créances ont tous les maux l'hérault en
date chez moi donc on est toutes les
nations aient eu lieu tout ce côté pas
autochtone sent-il la culture qu'on sera
emprunté les jeans golden ce qu'on fait
chez nous au paraguay mais qui viennent
d aj bout et il ya tout ça oui
puis on n'a pas nécessairement défini
deux protocoles à l'intérieur de ça je
pense qu'on est en train de réfléchir le
cet événement le veut nous amener en
tout cas se poser des questions via dire
jusqu'où je peux aller là dedans mais il
ya une chose qui est sûre au niveau de
l'appropriation culturelle c'est que
c'est une utilisation que je devrais à
mauvais escient d'un aspect de la
culture et dans ce cas-ci mais madame la
grande et elle prend le crédit pour une
culture qui n'est pas la seule et elle
fait un profit avec soin
le fait de l'argent elle une
reconnaissance oui donc il ya aussi qui
peut choquer je pense
les inuits dans tout ça dans l'histoire
l'historique l'appropriation culturelle
et quand même intéressante gens parlent
parfois ça a commencé dans la
dénonciation en fait de l'appropriation
culturelle a commencé dans les années 70
aux etats unis
non beaucoup plus fier c'est très récent
mais on regarde les années 70 alors
qu'ils avaient le mouvement american
indian movement et bien mouvement ils
ont d'activisme autochtone protection
des terres banquiers terreur dans les
années soixante treize ont eu une
bataille à one denis vous pourrez aller
voir ça entre autres est donc la cause
ont porté beaucoup et il ya plusieurs
célébrités qui se sont rassemblés
alentours du mouvement dont marlon
brando juste fait des belles choses dans
ma vie mais en fait une chose
intéressante en 1973 il a gagné le score
pour le meilleur acteur dans son film
pour un rôle dans son film le parrain
oui au moment de monter sur la scène ce
n'est pas lui qui est monté c'est chine
les neuf erreurs qui est une nappe h si
je me trompe pas et qui monte et qui a
dit monsieur brandon ne veut pas
accepter le prix puisque il ne reconnaît
pas la manière dont les autochtones sont
façon sont traités dans les films si
vous avez déjà vu un western des années
50-60 vous savez ce dont je parle
c'était premièrement c'était des acteurs
allochtone donc des non autochtones qui
jouait qui se peignaient la face en brun
rouge ensuite souvent on était dépeint
comme hostile ou un peu ivrogne
desseauve ajouté il y avait tout ça
aussi le thé qui nous faisait un peu mal
paraître
et c'est cette dénonciation le public
qui a été la première je pense en tout
cas à ce que j'ai vu dans mes recherches
et à partir de là mais là ça fait un peu
boule de neige on ne plus jouer
d'autochtones pendant longtemps les
choses au canada anglais salon un petit
peu évolué et puis finalement c'est
arrivé au québec l'été passé on en a
tellement vu au canada
ben oui oui examinant parce que même
l'appropriation autochtone passant pour
les communautés noires
est-ce que c'est plus pluvieux plus
récents je sais pas ça remonte peut-être
à la mesa à tout ça c'est toujours
côtoyé
rebondissent alors oui je t'ai rock et
l'appropriation culturelle ben c'est pas
toujours évident à définir et ses sols
le problème du temps c'est une femme et
une ligne qu'on va tracer dans le sable
oui certains va être plus à droite
d'autres plus à gauche pour d'autres ça
va être
oui ça c'est de l'appropriation wiland
sommes annoncées de l'empereur et de la
valorisation
donc c'est pas toujours évident
l'appropriation culturelle et c'est pour
ça que c'est important d'en parler mais
je pense que dans un débat comme celui
ci en tout cas les premières personnes
concernées ce sont les chanteuses de
gorge inuit le peuple inuit et si inouk
et si ce peuple l'a dit pour nous et
l'appropriation culturelle en tout cas
il faut il faut savoir les il faudrait
aller coûte oui c'est une des choses que
un autre point c'est aussi le fait que
la communauté louette au grand nord à
l'américano avuc s'affairent à peine 70
ans qu'on a beaucoup de contacts avec
les rôles en date et non oui dans nos
têtes alors le changeant et qui est
beaucoup plus isolé oui mais aussi le
fait que dans les années quand les
prêtres sont vus au grand nord il nous a
dit qu'on n'avait pas le droit de
chanter le chant de choeurs louis plus
si c'était presque perdu alors l'effort
que ça nous a pris deux rats prendre
réponse toutes les chansons de de se
rassembler de prendre l'énergie et 2d
conscient le fait que ça a été presque
perdu le fait que c'est vraiment un
bataille bataille c'est un challenge un
défi qu'on a fait de remettre le champ
du gange comme qu'en partie de notre
communauté de se réapproprier sa de
réapprendre comment devient on en a le
droit
oui on ait pu céder alors on a le droit
de chanter alors là que ça soit à cannes
ou un autochtone qui prend cet art
cette façon de chanter que j'ai fait un
partie intégrale de la communauté qu'il
fallait faire un défi vraiment un effort
de l'erea 30 qui me prend ça comme ça ne
demandez rien de nous pas écrire dans la
chanson c'est si une offensive qui sait
le temps de danser pour ça c'est très
important d'en discuter
oui oui au moins sait comment ça se fait
alors que la directrice lalala chef des
indiens news of the world d'ailleurs je
des contacts et oui j'ai pas eu de
réponse de l'organisation bon je pense
qu'elle ne parle pas français mais
j'aurais aimé que quelqu'un dans
l'organisation réagissent personne n'a
rappelé c'est dommage mais comment ça se
fait qu'ils ont laissé faire ça alors
j'ai lu à quelque part c'est un tanya
tagaq qui disait que dans le ca dans le
conseil d'administration des génisses
music awards premièrement il ya pas de
représentant inouk
donc ça c'est une des choses mais c'est
pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas essayé parce
que madame tagaq et qu'elle fraiseuse je
pense aussi ont essayé en amont de dire
bah écoute et l'on voit ce que ça ça
s'en vient on pense que c'est pas bien
qu'elle soit nommé pour telle ou telle
raison et malheureusement ça a pu
laisser rester lettre morte
d'après ce que j'ai vu les jeunes je les
rencontre et à calgary ya deux mois on a
fait une prestation d'ensemble qui va se
diffuser les interrogeant mais on s'est
parlé qui elle a retiré son album c'est
ça le mouvement elle elle comme pour
montrer le fait que l est pas d'accord
avec cet artiste là oui et puis là je
l'appuie beaucoup parce que elle utilise
son l'espace qu'elle prend comme artiste
de dire quelque chose que de dire non là
c'est notre sénat droit de protéger les
chants de gorge inuit
qui pour moi c'est une façon de
respecter et de montrer à danané message
aux artistes en général auteur d'un
total
vous avez le droit de nous inclure mais
pas d'assumer le chanteur de 26 ans
parce que c'est une question aussi que
c'est que la première fois que c'est
vraiment la première fois qu'on en
discute de dalton entre autochtones
autochtones oui mais c'est aussi le fait
que l'image on estime que les premières
nations les inuits et métis ont toutes
les mêmes
mais c'est pas le cas on est vraiment
des nations individuelles avec nos
propres cérémonies nos propres langnau 2
contre chansons mais c'est pas le fait
c'est vraiment avec le l'assimilation
que maintenant on est en train de
vraiment on essaie de 2006 les petits
morceaux qui nous reste dans la
communauté comme on faisait dire à jean
gaubert c'est pas quelque chose qui fait
partie du québec qui cotait de l'est
mais c'est approprié s'est adapté aussi
adopté par les nations qu'on en a plus
de champ de chansons aux dindes ans
parce que à cause de la simulation alors
pour éviter que le champ de gaz soient
assimilés encore se passe on est en
train de dire c'est assez
oui ce que je lisais ce qu'avait dit dix
ans les choses la directrice donc du
festival comment vous l'appelez festival
c'est le manito abi tchessa donc elle
elle dit ne pas croire que
l'appropriation culturelle est possible
entre les autochtones est d'accord
maintenant je suis pas d'accord je suis
je moi je suis d'année je suis je suis
pas au moral mais par contre je t'ai
élevé à montréal
oui jean theuret par ben je vais à
georgia gay qui est montréal je reste
c'est la réussite qui est le territoire
marocain
oui mais jamais dans ma musique je vais
approprié ou champions chanson en disant
voilà je suis artiste autochtone je peux
chanter cas ce que je veux parce que
c'est ce n'est pas le faire ce n'est pas
la façon de respecter le fait que les
chansons morax et ça fait partie la
nation que je vais pas partie
c'est tout et j'ai envie de faire
l'avocat du diable si la dame de la
grande avait reçu les enseignements
d'inuits de manière proprement lutte
conte le fait comme il faut à travers le
temps par une famille par des méthodes
généraux à ce que tu penses que ça a été
davantage acceptée non non plus vraiment
c'est quelque chose
le faso qu'on apprend le chant de gorge
c'est pas on prend pas des cours j'ai
pas quelque chose publique c'est plutôt
intime entre chanteuse de leur chanteuse
de love et entre mère et fille c'est pas
quelque chose cérémonial ça fait juste
partie comme vous
si on est né nu est on a le droit de
faire le changement je doute cetc les
règles qu'on a été enseigné si elle
voulait vraiment
ajouter le son il souhaite le chant de
gorge kata jack elle pourrait bien nous
éviter de faire l enregistrement et nous
donner le nom sur les cds en disant j'ai
invité cette chanteuse de l'orgie noël
pour respecter cette culture cette
communauté la individuel comme en
jésus-christ haïssons inuit
alors j'ai bien évité là au moins le
chant de gorge
il ya noël son côté authentique la côte
et de respect qui est montrée en
ajoutant en inclure un autre art mais
pour moi c'est je sais je connais bien
ces questions piges
merci pour le pour nous demander si un
punk mais en même temps le chant de
gorge évolué et là on le voit cette
semaine avec la chronique de mots
clarkson semaine justement elle est
consacrée aux chanteuses de gorge inuit
du mais ce sont des chanteuses de gorge
qui sont entrés dans la modernité en
transformant les chants de gorge en y
intégrant toutes sortes d'autres sont
d'autres styles ça c'est permis on peut
dénaturer le chant de gorge
bien sûr pour moi c'est chanteuse de
viande par exemple pour moi je je chante
tout seul non moment ça se fait à deux
oui déjà des championnats elle s'est
déjà un changement
moi je chante avec durablement itoïz
noté qui et qui fait beaucoup de l île
et dj alors moi j'ajoute monceaux de
chant de gorge avec ces sont les lui il
est nourri tous quand je fais le chant
de gorge avec oktoecho ça se fait on
fait notre répertoire mais aussi
j'ajoute mon sens qu'est ce que les
aînés m'ont dit c'est que le fait que
vous êtes inuit vous êtes le chantage de
gorge vous respectez le
les règlements vous pouvez les changer
mais toujours en disant ce n'est pas le
sens traditionnel c'est la façon de
respecter le fait que modifier artiste
je fais que je fais le change mais c'est
aussi de bien le dire ce n'est pas le
centre traditionnel ce n'est pas les
chansons je sais pas le fait que je je
me prends des morceaux moi même à des
chansons moi j'avais tout juste les 100
kg à alger a pris et j'ajoute le leçon à
musique alors oui moi c'est honnête on a
eu beaucoup de discussions entre
chanteuse blanche oui si on doit y
réfléchir aussi y voir quand est-ce
qu'on dépasse les limites pour nord
lorsqu on l'est on reste dans le respect
une des choses j'étais il ya un couple
d'années j'ai faire l'enregistrement
pour cirque du soleil
oui pour pour le show je me répète ça
quand même c'est un an s'était basé sur
s'était passé comme sur le pape au tac
tonnes et ils m'ont enregistré puis là
avant d'accepter ce n'était pas l'argent
ce n'était pas le fait d'être connu pour
le sort des salaires je suis allée
téléphonie mezani qui ont été des
chanteuses de gorge et j'ai demandé à ce
que ça serait correct qui me croient
mots voire deux pour le pour cette joie
là que ça va être diffusé qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
puis la laison dit le fait qu'ils vous
invitent qui vous prenez pas pas juste
les sons sur l'internet c'est
premièrement un façon de respecter mais
aussi le fait que ça va être ça fait de
vous le chanteuse sade vous vous
connaissez bien les chansons c'est pas
l'imitation c'est pas alors allez-y
alors j'avais pas la bénédiction mais
oui oui vous êtes d'accord on est
d'accord ça serait correct oui j'ai fait
les enregistrements qui c'était c'était
parfait alors c'est où j'allais aller
toujours rêve à nos professeurs
enseignante oui demande le protocole est
pas et pas toujours bien défini alors
c'est pour ça qu'il faut oui parfois
demandé parce que si nous aussi c'est
nouveau c'est le sujet de chanteuses de
gorge c'est vraiment parce que ça fait
pas longtemps qu'on en public en eau sur
le cd sur qui on évolue aussi et
règlements comment les protocoles
oui d'ailleurs je reviens d'un mot parce
que dans une chronique
elle nous fait entendre des chants de
gorge oui et elle nous fait entendre des
chants de gorge mongolia ouais est ce
que l'un et l'autre peuvent emprunter de
l'un et l'autre alors je ne regarde plus
pour un non non chacun d'entre nous les
artistes on jours aux pratiques parce
que moi je peux le faire le changement
le green est oui jamais je vais
l'enregistrer jamais je confirme chez
nous dans la nuit à la maison c'est fort
mais c'est mes preuves personnellement
jamais je pourrais dire je peux faire le
changement collier jamais je vais faire
un prestation être payé pour chanter
parce que c'est un manque de respect
pour les artistes qui le font en
mongolie eux aussi il fallait faire un
bataille pour le protéger alors pour moi
c'est entre artistes on s'échange les
sons on échange on je peux faire ça
aussi on m'a jeté les chansons qu'on
fait mais jamais on va dire que c'est un
autre ça fait partie de notre voiture
alors moi je le peux je vais les
respecte tout le monde mais en échange
entre un artiste de chant de gorge
mongolienne huîtres est très possible
c'est pas de la première crise à
d'ailleurs on a chanté une excuse mans
d'ailleurs on a chanté avec des femmes
d'afrique afrique du sud
ils font des leçons très vite avec la
future mouture wii puis on a fait
impression de chant de gorge quand on
sait écouter l'autre on se dit ça
on fait les mains sont là on a pris le
temps de chanter ensemble
ça m'a donné des frissons parce que
c'était comme sakho 6 femme qui parlait
pas l'anglais qui parlait pas français
qui parle et on pouvait pas s'échanger
de mots mais on a chanté ensemble ça
bouge ça c'était incroyable oui mais
c'est un honneur qu'on sait respecter en
disant nous on fait ça où cette cendre
peut mélanger informelle avec ce qui
arrive maintenant il le fait que des
artistes donc une artiste hinault que
des artistes vont se retirer des
yvelines dj noise music hall
c'est pas au désavantage de ces artistes
là on ne les entendra pas on ne les
verra pas je pense pas c'est le cas le
fait qu' il montre les montres avec iph
indécision il fait un monde de magie
sort de respect pour leurs communautés
c'est la communauté qui vont l'acheter
libre et déjà sur facebook je vois tout
le monde qui l'appuient dans la
communauté ont dit oui c'est le temps de
dire non c'est assez en ce respect on
demande qu'on le respect et c'est pas ça
s'appelle inverse le fait qu'il est si
célèbre et ave être évités déjà je le
vois sur le facebook qui a établi par
tous pour mener son bien a réagi la
musique c'est pas seulement sur une star
wars qui va être écouté sur le fait que
ce respect à ces comme artistes inuit
comme chanteuses de gorge nouée
qui veut de moteur qui va inspirer les
autres en haïti en disant oui elle a
raison on va l'appuyer
on a l'habitude de chanter pour jour
c'est tout on voit que l'intégrité on à
l'actualité des dernières semaines
notamment avec toujours des oiseaux mais
bon on en est
il avait dix pensent maintenant il était
surtout valeur extrêmement importante
pour le premier peuple peu importe le
peuple je pense que ça et ça ça
transparaît dans tout ce qui se passe
oui vous les emplois même si parfois ça
peut ça peut faire un petit peu de recul
mais ça va faire comme tu disais ça va
faire avancer un peu plus tard puis ça
va ça va permettre la discussion c'est
important oui déjà de la communauté a
été célébré oui en sa qualité
alors j'ai l'impression que c'est ça ce
qui est en train de se faire dans la
nouveauté nous étions là on la regarde
comme quelqu'un de bons ballons disant
hey lalala la fortitude si on dit la
force de série no we de prendre sa
musique à dire non te dire quelque chose
positive pour protéger le chant de gorge
et déjà c'était vraiment une très belle
conversation
alors si on veut découvrir les chants de
gorge de votre part par exemple ou
est-ce que vous êtes là prochainement ça
serait vraiment agréable d'aller vous
voir sur scène de découvrir le chant de
gorge par une chambre voisine et 9 bat
sur le si vous faire charger de porto
rico
on l'a des prestations et avec mark
rothko siéger dépréciations c'est tout
pour le moment c'est en somme était mon
nom sur youtube vous allez me voir avec
ma fille vous sentiez avec votre fille
oui c'est ça je suis très fière de ce
qu'elle avait à la 18 plus jeune fils de
8 ans qu'il sait comment si elle est un
peu plus timide donc on voit qu'il ya de
la relève chez les chanteuses de gorge
inuit
merci beaucoup nina sega le ritz est
devenu nous nous rencontrer surtout
d'être venu préciser donc ce débat là
autour de l'appropriation culturelle
entre premières nations et les inuits
je donnerai merci il appelle un dernier
mot pour terminer mais en fait on
continue la discussion je pense qu'on
vienne en ouvrir une nouvelle pour le
bon docteur le respect d'une nation par
rapport à l'ordre faut pas oublier qu'on
est toutes des nations se ferme sont on
respecte ceux qui parlent je pense que
ça c'est important
voilà respectés et écoutés oui merci
beaucoup isabelle isabelle picard
chen merci à vous tous d'avoir été là
encore une fois cette semaine vous
pouvez continuer la conversation sur les
réseaux sociaux sur facebook entre
autres si vous avez des questions vous
pouvez les poser également et bien sûr
des réactions des commentaires nous
allons vous lirez vous répondre merci
beaucoup
à très bientôt
[Musique]